[Música]
y llegamos a China porque cientos de
manifestantes protestaron a la entrada
de la sucursal del Banco Central de la
ciudad de Jason luego de descubrir que
no podían retirar su dinero y recibir
informaciones que aseguraban que el
director de la empresa matriz había
huido y estaba buscado por delito
financieros vamos entonces a la capital
de gigante asiático Ahí está nuestro
corresponsal Adrián foncillas Adrián lo
saludo muy buena noche y le pregunto
Cuál es la situación actual y cómo se
originó este llamado también corralito
Bueno hoy han empezado a devolverse los
primeros depósitos son los menores de
50.000 yuanes unos 7.300 Dólares pero no
hay aún una hoja de ruta para el resto
Así que la crisis se ha atenuado pero no
se ha resuelto hace ya tres meses que
casi medio millón de clientes no pueden
acceder a sus ahorros pensaron al
principio que era un fallo informático
pero ante el paso del tiempo y la falta
de respuestas se pusieron
comprensiblemente nerviosos y empezaron
las protestas a principios esporádicas
pero que culminaron el domingo pasado
con una pelea masiva en la calle de un
millar de afectados con cientos de tipos
todos vestidos de blanco probablemente
matones a sueldo del gobierno local y el
asunto sorprende porque las protestas en
la calle eran muy frecuentes años atrás
no tenían que ver con el sistema
político sino con cuestiones cotidianas
como una fábrica contaminante en el
vecindario un escándalo alimentario
alguna corruptera un despido masivo pero
hacía tiempo que no se veía a tanta
gente en la calle y sorprende también
por la forma chapucera con la que se ha
gestionado y que parece saca el viejo
libro de estilo no solo con aquellos
matones sino con argucias como cambiar a
Los afectados el código de salud del
teléfono a rojo para impedirles
desplazarse y sumarse a las protestas es
decir todo remite a un escenario que
parecía ya superado Adrián también le
pregunto Entonces si es previsible
alguna crisis política o económica en
China teniendo en cuenta este presidente
bueno el misterio es como unos bancos se
han quedado sin blanca y las
explicaciones que se han dado hablan de
bandas criminales de operaciones
fraudulentas de fondos públicos atraídos
a través de turbias plataformas online
es decir se habla de conductas
delictivas concretas Pero existe la duda
de si esta crisis no responde a
problemas estructurales de la banca
rural en China que es muy importante
porque atiende a los agricultores y a
los pequeños negocios en las provincias
más atrasadas y esos bancos pequeños
hace tiempo que arrastraban problemas de
morosidad y de de liquidez Así que es un
problema sistémico lo cual no significa
que vaya a haber un colapso inmediato
nacional es habitual que en China si
protestan cuatro personas en la calle
anunciemos un diamantén Y si hay un
escándalo financiero anunciamos la caída
de ese gigante económico con pies de
barro lo que sí está claro es que este
episodio Lima la confianza en el
gobierno Porque aquí las crisis
económicas son siempre crisis políticas
por ese papel paternalista del gobierno
y que a veces llega a estemos ridículos
como prohibir por ejemplo las películas
de terror para los jóvenes los chinos
jamás tienden a pensar que el gobierno
les protege de todos los males y además
tienen una Concepción bastante naif de
sus inversiones muchos invierten en
bolsa pensando que si las cosas van mal
el gobierno lo arreglará y lo que ha
pasado en genam no tiene que ver con
unas inversiones arriesgadas sino con
los ahorros depositados en un banco Así
que más le conviene al gobierno arreglar
la situación cuanto antes